George Washington University law
professor Jonathan Turley joins us
tonight
professor Facebook trolls I mean I'm not
for that but I'm a little disappointed
that that appears to be the sum total of
this yeah it is amazing isn't it I mean
you wonder whether Putin is back in
Moscow watching the women's March is
saying well those 12 guys really did a
lot I mean you didn't really have to
send these guys to till to the United
States to divide us politically that was
sort of a pre-existing condition what's
also amazing is how gratuitous this is
you know that after the election they
start throwing protests on opposing
sides and it's just as striking how
little really could have been
accomplished by this but at the end of
the day the most interesting thing about
this indictment is one adjective
unwitting you know after a year after
all these plea agreements after all
these interviews they really don't have
any evidence of anyone knowingly
engaging with Russians not even
mentioning the Trump Tower meeting where
they knew they were Russians so there
doesn't seem to be any of their there
after a year so we're getting close to
20 indictments so far and none of them
speak directly to the underlying charges
I mean their perjury their money
laundering their failure to register as
a foreign agent I mean I'm not saying
they're insignificant but they're
skirting the edge of in signal
insignificant are we gonna get actual
charges against anybody would you say
well that is what was also striking
about this the charges themselves are
actually quite conventional things like
identity theft which is very common with
Russian sources hacking what isn't
conventional obviously is the context
this is one of the largest indictments
for trying to interfere with an election
it's just that the evidence of any
success in that seems from quite minimal
maybe people have criticized rod
Rosenstein for saying there was no
evidence of this impacting the election
but I think that what he was saying was
this we haven't really found anything
quite significant in these activities
now having said that we should be
concerned about the hacking that went on
I think that was the most significant
app